the case of child Q prompted protests in
a serious case review
why was a 15 year old black girl strip
searched by the Metropolitan Police at
school without an appropriate adult
present
but data released by The Children's
commissioner for England has revealed
that hundreds of young people go through
such intrusive searches each year often
unaccompanied a strip search is you know
your most intimate parts are searched
for any child that's going to be
traumatic and concerning and so I think
it's for safeguarding it's absolutely
clear that an appropriate adult should
be there it's actually a legal
requirement except in the most urgent of
cases but between 2018 and 2020 650
children aged 10 to 17 were strip
searched 58 of whom were black
95 were boys and on nearly a quarter of
occasions an appropriate adult was not
present
in fact in 2018 more than two-thirds of
those strip searched alone were black
boys
the numbers are so high because they
demonstrate that there's an issue within
the Metropolitan Police and its
treatment of black communities across
London unfortunately young black
children are not afforded innocence and
the same rights as their white Pairs and
I'm surprised by these statistics but
incredibly horrified
in the child queue case four officers
are being investigated for gross
misconduct
the Metropolitan Police says it's
progressing at PACE to ensure that
children subject to intrusive searches
are dealt with respectfully and new
measures are being introduced requiring
an inspector to give Authority before
such a search can take place
solicitor Kevin Donahue has represented
children who've been through the
experience
there is a violation by police officers
which is very severely felt and one of
personal integrity and their bodily
autonomy which has been invaded and it
is an event that cannot be undone
in more than half of all child strip
searches no further action was taken
it's left the children's commissioner
questioning why so many are carried out
in the first place Emma birchley Sky
News